c'est vrai qu'avec mon épouse nous avons
passé deux ans et demi dans un camping
car il est bien dans le micro mon père
parce que parce que la locataire ne
voulait pas partir la semaine dans les
lieux c'est c'était son choix moi moi ce
qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
j'ai récupéré mon appartement grâce
notamment à Cyril et à d'autres médias
j'ai récupéré mon appartement mais je
m'inquiète pour les milliers de couples
qui sont dans notre dans notre état et
qui sont à la rue bien souvent ils
dorment devant chez eux dans des
voitures parce qu'il peut apprendre chez
eux donc moi je voudrais savoir si si
vous le gouvernement vous allez faire
quelque chose pour modifier la loi c'est
la loi qui m'a le foutu elle le
propriétaire a toujours tort le
locataire a toujours raison c'est comme
ça donc ce que je veux savoir moi ce
soir c'est si vous allez faire quelque
chose si vous pensez compter faire
quelque chose pour modifier cet état de
fait alors la réponse est oui est arrivé
monsieur si j'ai bien compris c'est pas
quelqu'un qui a squatter votre maison
c'est quelqu'un qui dont vous avez loué
votre maison et qui vous avez des
souhaité dénoncer ce qui est tout à fait
votre droit le bail fallait mettre 6
mois pour qu'elle parte enfin le contrat
et puis et puis elle est restée c'est
tout à fait alors aujourd'hui vous avez
raison quand il y a quelqu'un squatte il
y a quelqu'un force une maison rentre
dedans on a des moyens de l'expulser
peut-être qu'on fait pas assez vite on a
une bonne expulsé ce qui est très
compliqué vous êtes parfaitement raison
il invite dans la loi quand quelqu'un
est venu légalement mais reste
illégalement on met beaucoup de temps à
obtenir la procédure d'ailleurs je
voudrais dire monsieur que quand vous
avez saisi la force publique
c'est-à-dire les policiers je crois
qu'ils sont intervenus assez vite le
problème c'était la procédure judiciaire
Camille bouton puis après quand votre
huissier abordé vous le savez bien les
forces publiques on l'a fait donc je
crois que moins de 15 jours cet effet
peut-être qu'on aurait pu faire plus
rapide mais c'était fait il y a un
député ici qui s'appelle Guillaume
casparian un député Renaissance voilà
qui a une proposition de loi que moi je
soutiens et que je vais m'efforcer dans
les semaines il y a beaucoup de
parlementaires qui sont là à faire
adopter qui répond exactement à ce que
vous dites quand vous avez un locataire
donc vous avez dénoncé le contrat
légalement et je vais donner toujours
raison de propriétaire c'est un rapport
de force qui est normal mais quand vous
êtes dans votre droit et bien ce
qu'après prévu monsieur le député
casparian c'est qu'on puisse utiliser
évidemment la force publique accélérer
les procédures pour faire comme si
c'était un squat si j'ose dire classique
donc ça répond parfaitement je crois
qu'il a eu l'idée en partie grâce à des
choses qui dépendent la construction
mais aussi on vous regardant et on vous
écoutant et ben donc oui et j'espère que
la loi de Monsieur député qui a été
déposé il a il s'est en regardant Pierre
et Marie si on voilà vous n'avez pas de
micro mais vous pouvez me faire des
sites vous les avez vu la tête oui c'est
en voyant le cas de Pierre et Marie ce
que vous avez
il va vous recevoir
avec eux de tout ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi ça s'est passé comment est-ce
qu'il prévoit alors je sais que dans le
cas particulier c'est qu'en plus cette
dame elle avait je crois un enfant
handicapé si j'ai bien compris la
difficulté une question de relogement
mais elle a une enfant avec elle qui est
pas qui
c'est voilà mais par ailleurs par
ailleurs monsieur castorium prévoit non
seulement d'accélérer le travail des
forces de l'ordre et d'accélérer le
travail de la justice parce que vous
avez beaucoup de temps malheureusement
avoir vous avez mis deux ans plus de 2
ans à avoir la réponse que le fait
d'avoir médiatisé l'affaire accélérer
nous-mêmes je regardais votre émission
ce soir là ah bah merci et je reviens
pas tous les soirs je veux bien faudrait
et j'ai dit j'ai
ça vous inquiéterait tous se dire et
finalement il va se passer
je vous ai vu monsieur et d'abord je me
suis dit quand vous avez quand même dit
au début si je peux me permettre qui
avait un problème avec la police qui
donc je me suis inquiété j'ai appelé
et j'ai un peu osé le ton et j'ai un peu
osé le ton mais j'ai aussi le temps de
sa faute voilà puisque on sait tous
aperçu et une question que la force
publique une fois qu'elle était requie
parce que moi vous êtes pas de sa
mission la force physique n'était pas
requise c'est ça et juste après votre
huissier a donné et a été requise et
cette personne était expulsée donc j'ai
compris en regardant votre émission on
avait effectivement après dans la loi et
le député sans virage Julien demandé à
déposer sa proposition de loi et donc je
pense que c'est une bonne chose qu'elle
soit adoptée
vous avez retrouvé votre appartement
ça c'est le truc classique mais on a
retrouvé notre notre logement
la partie adverse la partie adverse fait
toujours tout ce qu'elle peut
aujourd'hui on était convoqué
par l'avocat et la feignante
ce sera intéressant que vous rencontriez
monsieur député pour comprendre aussi
c'est ça une loi qui fonctionne elles
vont se rencontrer vous pouvez même
aller habiter chez eux un petit peu
ça vous pouvez faire quelques travaux
parce qu'apparemment voilà merci c'est
très bien voilà comme ça ça voilà en
tout cas vous nous tenez au courant
merci en tout cas pierre et Maryse ça
aurait été là